[MUSIC PLAYING]
KYLE STORY: Well, thank
you everyone for coming.
We appreciate you coming out
and joining this session.
I'm Kyle Story.
I'm a computer vision
engineer at Descartes Labs.
And today, I want to tell you
about how computers see Earth,
a machine learning approach
to understanding satellite
imagery at scale.
And so there's a few
things that I'm hoping,
depending where you're
coming to this talk
from, that you might take away.
First, I'm hoping that
everybody will understand
how we've been able to build
a platform within the Google
Cloud, how that's
allowed us to provide
an efficient development
environment for building
machine learning
models and then scale
those models across
large data sets
to be able to understand
the entire globe.
Second, I'm hoping that you will
take away the types of problems
that we've found
compelling and that we've
been able to address using
satellite imagery and machine
learning techniques.
And then third,
hopefully get you
thinking about the
types of problems
that you might be able to
address with these data--
with this type of
infrastructure and how
you might be able to address
some of your business problems,
whether that's monitoring
infrastructure,
supply chains, agriculture,
even understanding
the natural ecosystem.
So the world is
teeming with activity,
whether that's manmade
infrastructure, like here
in the zoom in sports
stadium inside of a city;
or that's agriculture,
shown here,
with crop circles
in South America;
or the natural ecosystem.
There are things happening
all over the entire globe
all the time, and
satellite imagery
is a particularly
effective way of being
able to zoom in and
understand what is
going on all across the globe.
So there's a big
dynamic range in what we
want to be able to understand.
We want to zoom all the
way in to the human scale
of a few meters,
or a meter or less.
And then we
simultaneously want to be
able to extend these
analyses across countries
and continents.
So it presents a big challenge.
In satellite imagery,
we are at the beginning
of what we think of
as a regime change
in simply just the data set.
So previously, satellites
were big and expensive,
costing over $100
million, weighing a ton.
Companies and governments
could only send up
a few of these at a time.
And so while these
satellites provide
excellent and
incredible information,
you can't monitor
the entire globe
with any sort of
regular cadence.
With the advent of CubeSats
and smaller satellites,
that's really changing.
So now, companies are
able to build satellites
for $60,000, $70,000 a
piece, these small things.
And then, they can
launch entire fleets up
into the sky to be able
to effectively monitor
the entire globe
almost in real time.
And so what we're looking
at for the near future is
whereas the data that
underlies Google Earth
takes approximately
two years to complete
a new picture of
the entire world,
we expect that within
around five years,
private satellites will be
able to cover the entire globe
every 20 minutes.
So this is a completely
different class
of the types of problems
that you can address and then
also a completely different
regime for the big data
that you need to
deal with in order
to make sense of all
of these information.
So Descartes, in order to
make sense of these data,
we're building a living
digital atlas of the globe.
And so during this talk,
I wanted to tell you a bit
about that and then how
we're using machine learning
to understand the value in the
information in these pictures.
So we can think about
this as a classic big data
challenge with the three Vs--
Volume, Variety, and Velocity.
And so in this context, volume
is what it usually means,
the massive amount
of data that we
need to be able to
pull in and work with.
Variety, in this case, means
the different types of data
that we want to
synthesize into analyses,
and I'll talk about all
these in more detail.
And velocity here, I
really mean two things.
I mean first, being able
to access all of that data
efficiently but then also
being able to analyze and scale
your analysis across the globe
rather than having someone
look at individual pictures.
So to kind of work through
those with some numbers
and a bit of detail,
global satellite data sets
are very big.
This composite that
we made is comprised
of 3.1 trillion pixels per band,
and the Landsat satellite that
took this has collected over
70 trillion pixels between 2013
and 2017.
So that comprises 320
terabytes on disk,
and that's just one
satellite among many.
So we've processed around
10 to 12 terabytes of data--
sorry, petabytes of data onto
our platform at this point.
And this is just going
to expand exponentially.
But just to give you a bit of an
image in your head of what that
looks like, let's take one
satellite, the Sentinel
Satellite, and take all of
the picture that it's taken
and print each individual band
on a one-millimeter thick sheet
of paper.
Stack that up, and
that would form
a column that's 410
kilometers tall, so
from the surface of the Earth
up into the thermosphere.
So it's a lot of data.
The data variety that
we're working with
comes from different
types of sensors
that we want to be able to work
with and synthesize together.
So here on the left,
there are passive sensors,
like normal pictures
that you would take.
In the middle, there
are active sensors,
which actually send
down radiation or radar,
and then receive the
signal and interfere
it to get 3D information about
the surface of the Earth.
That's called synthetic
aperture radar.
And then, there's
near-infrared data
that actually measures
the thermal emission
from sources on the ground.
And then, there's all
kinds of other georelevant
data like weather, cell
phones, derived products,
derived mass, customer data.
So we want to be able to put all
of this into the Cloud in a way
that customers can access
in an efficient way
to be able to build these
types of analysis algorithms.
And then velocity-- so
thinking about the--
how long it takes to work
with these types of data,
let's consider again
the Sentinel Satellite.
So if we take one year of
data, Sentinel Satellite
covers the entire earth
approximately once every
five days.
Let's now chop up the
entire earth into 512
by 512 tiles at
10-meter resolution
and then give a human
analyst 10 seconds
to look at each picture.
That would take
them 130 years to go
through one year of satellite
data for one satellite.
So obviously, that's silly.
We're not going to do that.
But that kind of
illustrates the problem
of the old way of thinking
about satellite imagery analysis
and why we need new approaches.
And then also for velocity,
thinking about the computation
that's required to handle
these types of data.
So again, coming back to this
composite that we created,
this was made from
processing over
a petabyte of NASA imagery.
And we did all this
processing within the Cloud
using preemptible VMs.
And by spinning of
30,000 cores, we
were able to process and create
this image in under 16 hours.
So this is actually even
larger than the throughput
that we need for the
current data sets,
but it demonstrates
the capability
that Google Cloud
will be able to scale
as the data that
I'm talking about
continues to grow in
the way that we expect.
So to handle all of these
data, as I mentioned
at the beginning, we're building
a data refinery, or a platform,
to better understand our planet.
And so what we want
to provide is ready
access to petabytes
of geospatial data
and then scalable
compute to back that up
and be able to create automated
and scalable analyses.
And these are just a few
of the satellite sources
that we have on
platform right now.
And this is going to
just continue to grow.
So I've talked a lot about
all of this raw data.
But what's really
important is that the value
lies in the information in
those pictures and the decisions
that you can make
from that information,
not in the raw pixels.
So it's important for
us to be able to sift
through all of that data and
arrive at decision points--
being able to monitor
something in supply chain
or make a decision
about whether we're
going to go here or go there.
So being able to pull together
all different types of data--
so here is [INAUDIBLE]
over Tokyo.
You can see the ships
coming into port;
being able to understand
the changes over time--
this middle image are segmented
crop fields in Nebraska
that were created by looking
at detecting edges in images
and then looking at which
edges persist over time
to be able to tell
what fields are what;
and then using machine
learning, which I'll
spend the second half of
my talk talking about,
to be able to analyze all
of these data at scale.
And then what this gives you
is really a geospatial refinery
for business intelligence, so
again, taking all this data,
processing it, and then turning
into value and decisions
that you can use.
So what the platform
actually looks
like, then, is effectively
a Python API for Earth,
is what we like to call it.
So let's say, for
example, you want
to take-- we want to gather
Sentinel imagery over Taos
in northern New Mexico.
If you were to start from
scratch trying to go directly
to the satellite source, this
would be quite challenging.
But for us, it
only takes three--
four lines here--
importing the package,
specifying the
location, doing a search
over all of that giant
catalog of metadata
to find the Sentinel imagery
over this place in 2017
between March 12 and
March 20, and then
taking all those
numbers and burning them
into an image or a picture that
you can actually see and work
with.
So under the hood,
what we've provided
is fast access to over petabyte
of data on the platform.
The search function for
searching through the metadata
is done with
Elasticsearch, and it
provides a millisecond response
times over all of those data.
And then an automatic
tiling system,
so you don't have to worry
about putting together
different images and making sure
you register them correctly--
all this.
And if you want more detail
about the underlying platform,
you can go back and watch
Tim's talk from yesterday,
[? IO263. ?]
So the second half
of the talk, I
want to talk about the
machine learning approach
that we've taken to-- trying
to understand these data
and derive value from it.
So I think another
important change
that at least the geospatial
data community is going through
right now is whereas
previously images were thought
of as something that a
human analyst could pull up
on their screen and then look
through and study and annotate,
with this massive amount
of data, as I mentioned,
that's no longer sufficient.
And so we should start
thinking of these images
and all of these data
as input to computers,
input to algorithms, what
computers are seeing out
of this rather than what
humans are seeing out of this.
And it really
changes how you think
about the type of analysis
and the type of questions
you can answer.
And so that's what's
going to be required
to automate data analysis that
you can scale across the globe.
And then, this also
encourages us to simply think
differently about the types of
questions that one can answer.
So hopefully, I can get you
all thinking through this talk.
So a little bit about
what the input data
looks like from-- so now, me,
as a computer vision engineer,
I come in, and I
say, how am I going
to create a new useful tool?
So let's start with
the input data.
As I mentioned previously, there
are several different types
of images.
The most common are
passive sensors, where
the sun is the light source.
It shines, reflects off
the surface of the Earth,
and you take a picture
of that reflected light.
So that's like
normal CCD cameras.
Then, there are active sensors,
which are their own light
source, so like for example,
synthetic aperture radar,
which sends a radar
signal down, reflects it
off the surface of the
Earth, and then receives
that full wave
front, which it can
measure and interfere and
then use that to reconstruct
3D models of the ground.
So we collect these data.
And many of the algorithms that
I'm going to be working with
are supervised algorithms.
And so oftentimes, it'll
look like image target pairs.
So here, for
example, on the left,
I have a picture over a city
of high-resolution satellite
imagery.
And then on the right,
I have a labeled image
for where all the buildings are.
And so this is the
type of input data
that would go into
training an algorithm.
Because the platform
is in Google Cloud,
it's trivial to be able to
process all of these data
and create these pairs
directly in the Cloud
and then save them
to Cloud Storage
and then be able to access
them seamlessly without having
to use any local resources.
For those of you who think
about analyzing imagery,
I just wanted to highlight
a few of the similarities
and differences between
processing normal imagery.
So many things are
similar, but there
are some key
conceptual differences.
So in particular,
satellite imagery
usually has a known size
and scale with units.
Pixels usually correspond to
a specific size on the ground.
In terms of data
augmentation, these images
are left, right, and
rotationally invariant.
So you can flip them all
around to augment your data
sets easily.
One of the key differences
is that often times,
we're interested
in finding things
right at the limits of the
resolution of the imagery, so
small objects within images.
Whereas in normal imagery,
whether it's the cheese example
that we saw from AutoML
that piece of cheese
takes up almost the entire
image, here we're looking for--
you saw the buildings--
we're looking
for those little specks.
So in terms of thinking
about transfer learning,
the scales can be different.
There are almost always
confusers in the data,
like clouds, haze, and shadows.
So that requires a
lot of pre-processing.
And I'll show a little bit
later dealing with that.
And then in normal imagery,
there's usually three bands.
Whereas in satellite imagery,
we can have an arbitrary number
of bands.
For example, the
Sentinel Satellite
from Europe that I've
referenced a few times
has 12 bands from the
visible all the way up
into thermal bands.
And then a similarity that
works well with being--
working within the Cloud is that
these problems are generally
embarrassingly parallel.
You can take a full stack
of images in normal image
processing, or you
can tile up the earth
into a stack of images,
and then send them off
to an arbitrary
number of processors
to be able to run that--
run those jobs in parallel.
OK, so now we've
thought a little bit
about the input data.
How do we want to
analyze these data?
Well, there's three
sort of dimensions
that I like to think
about when thinking
about satellite imagery--
spatial, spectral,
and temporal.
So spatial is just where
you are on the ground, so
the 2D context of where
you are on the earth
or within an image.
Spectral are the different
wavelengths of light
that we record when we take
imagery in different bands.
And then temporal is for a
given location, obviously.
As you take pictures over
time, you can see what changes.
And so by combining
these different aspects
in different ways, we can access
different types of problems.
So for example, computer
vision will usually
be combining spatial and
spectral information, where
you're trying to understand the
spatial context within an image
and then look for spectral
signatures of different types
of objects or land cover that
you want to be able to find
and map.
And spectral and
temporal can often
be used to look for
and monitor change.
So for example, looking at crop
fields over a growing season,
you can see how the plants are
growing and changing over time.
And then obviously, many
of the final solutions
will be hybrid approaches
that will combine everything,
and I'll talk about one
of those at the end.
So because we have chosen
to work within Google Cloud,
building these ML models is
a really efficient process.
So we work within
virtual machines
on Google Cloud Platform.
That allows us to easily
scale the resources
that we need to process images,
train algorithms as needed.
And then, we're able to maintain
environmental consistency
from that development
and training
process all the way
through to deployment
by using Docker and Kubernetes.
Because our data
live in Google Cloud,
it provides us super fast access
to that giant body of data.
And then for training, we can
download smaller sets to VMs
or work with it
directly from the Cloud.
And then we can deploy at scale.
So as I mentioned, most
of these are embarrass--
at the deployment stage,
most of these models
are an embarrassingly
parallel problem.
And so we can simply spawn up an
arbitrary number of processors.
If I want to run a
model over the world
or over the United
States, I can just
spawn up that
number of processors
and get the results that
much faster, and then
results are saved
directly to the Cloud.
So from research
to building models
to deploying those models,
working within the Cloud
provides us an incredibly
efficient environment
for doing this work.
So now, I would like to tell
you about three different more
specific machine learning
approaches that we've taken
and the types of
problems that we've
been able to access with those.
So I'll dig in a
little bit deeper
into the machine learning side
of the models we're building.
So the first is
object detection.
For those of you who are not
computer vision engineers,
the basic idea of
object detection
is exactly what those
words sound like.
You want to find objects.
And so for example,
here, we're looking
for electric substations.
So you want to find that object,
draw a box around it, and say,
there it is.
The particular
implementation that we've
been working with so far is
called a Single Shot MultiBox
Detector, SSD.
Single shot because it
takes a single forward pass
through the
architecture; MultiBox
because it uses a set
of predefined boxes
rather than dynamically
finding those boxes;
and then detector because
it detects things.
How it works-- in one slide--
is this algorithm, as I said,
predefines a set of boxes.
And then for each
of those boxes,
it uses a convolutional
neural net
to generate a set of features.
And then, it finally
predicts the competence of
whether or not that box
contains the object of interest,
so basically, it boils
this search problem down
into a classification problem.
So here, this is from the paper
that defined this architecture.
The blue box has the highest
probability of being a cat.
And the red box has the highest
probability of being a dog.
So we've taken that
and modified it
to work with satellite
imagery, and here's an example
of the results of that process.
So using OpenStreetMap
for the known locations
of electric
substations, we've been
able to train this
using NAIP imagery,
so that's the National
Agriculture Imagery Program
that covers the United States.
This particular data set has
imagery at 60 centimeters
per pixel in four bands.
And we've trained
this algorithm to be
able to find all the rest of
the substations in the United
States.
So that was one
example, and once we
have this setup with all the
imagery easily accessible
and the modeling
framework in place,
it's easy to train a
wide variety of models
across the industrial
supply chain
to be able to find
these objects.
So here are just two
examples of being
able to find storage tanks,
being able to find boats.
But you can just let
your imagination run wild
for what you would be
able to do with this.
The second class of models
that we worked with a lot
is called semantic segmentation.
So the basic idea with this--
as opposed to object
detection where you're
trying to find
objects, here, you're
trying to say for every
pixel in an image,
is that pixel part
of a class or not?
So the example on
the left hand side
is that high-resolution
imagery, again, from NAIP.
And then the right hand
side is the probability of
whether or not each pixel
is inside a building.
So similarly, how
it works-- here,
we define a deep
convolutional neural net.
And convolutional neural nets
are a particularly effective
architecture for these
types of analysis,
because they take into account
the two-dimensional context
of an image.
So if you've ever
zoomed in on Google Maps
and then zoomed
way out, once you
zoom all the way
into pixel scales,
it can be really hard to
tell what you're looking at.
And you actually
need to zoom out
and be able to see
that spatial context.
That's kind of conceptually
what convolutional neural nets
are able to capture.
So we define a deep
neural net architecture--
in this case, a U-Net, and then
create a bunch of these image
target pairs that I
mentioned at the beginning,
so in this case about
10,000 to 20,000 of these,
and then train the model
within the Cloud Platform.
And this is what the
output looks like.
So these are detections for
my model over LA County.
So you can see the
high-resolution imagery
on the far right hand side.
This is the raw
probability map output.
And then in the
middle, these have now
been segmented into
individual buildings.
And so what's
especially powerful here
is once we have this model,
as I mentioned earlier,
being able to run
this over large areas.
So I was able to map all
the buildings in California
by hitting Run,
going home to sleep.
And then by the time I
got back in the morning,
we had a map of all the
buildings in California.
And in principle, we can do
this over the entire world.
Another type of
segmentation that we've
been able to have success
with is using neural nets
to mask out clouds.
As you remember
at the beginning,
I mentioned this is one
of the pernicious problems
with satellite imagery is
clouds exist, much to our bane--
the bane of our existence,
I would say rather.
And so by training a neural
net to find clouds and cloud
shadows, we can now
automatically mask out
these out of images and
then be able to remove
those parts from the analysis.
And this can always get better.
This will be an
ongoing challenge.
But this has been a
particularly successful approach
for being able to deal with
these types of non-idealities
in the data.
Another approach is what I've
called here core segmentation.
So this is actually basically
a transfer learning approach,
where we start from a ResNet-50,
a pre-trained algorithm,
and then we tap into one of the
lower-resolution feature layers
and then simply add a
final classification
step to say whether or not
each of those coarser pixels
is the type of
thing-- in this case,
windmills-- that
we're looking for.
And so we've taken
advantage of the fact
that ResNet's been able to
train on many, many, many, many
images.
And then with a relatively
small number of examples--
I think over 1,000-- a few
hundred to 1,000 examples
here--
we've been able to
train an algorithm that
can find and map windmills.
So this has been done across the
United States and across India.
And then finally, it's
still semantic segmentation.
But a bit of a simpler model
is simply pixel classification,
so taking that--
remember I mentioned
the spectral information
within each pixel, what you see
in different bands,
and then feeding that
into a random forest classifier
and then just training it
with a bunch of data
to say whether or not
each pixel is land or water.
So this is in the Mekong Delta.
And you can see it clearly
gets the oceans and the rivers.
And then, there are a lot of
rice paddies in these areas,
so that's kind of what
this speckling pattern
that you see throughout
the Mekong Delta is here.
A third type--
and this is fairly
different-- is what we
called visual search.
So I'll demo this
in just a second.
But the idea is that this is
a website that you can go to.
You can click anywhere
either in the United States
or on the earth.
And it will simply
find other places
that are visually similar.
So let me go into a
little bit of detail
on what's going on in the hood,
and then we can play around
with this a little bit.
So what's going on is that we've
taken the entire data set, so
the entire globe.
We've chopped it up into
lots of little pieces.
And then we feed
each of those pieces
through a convolutional
neural net
to produce a set of features.
And then we simply search for
nearest neighbors of features.
So in even more
detail than that,
we started from a
customized ResNet-50.
So started from ResNet-50
using all of that--
the training that had gone
into producing that model.
And then remember, I mentioned
that often times, you're
looking for small
things in images
that are different from
normal image processing.
So we fine-tuned trained
that with the OpenStreetMap
data set and then
also some unsupervised
autoencoding to
be able to produce
a useful set of features.
We then encouraged those
features to either be 0 or 1,
so binarized that
set of features.
And the result of that
process is that for each tile,
we get 512 binary bits, 0 or 1.
Then, we can simply search
for which sets of the features
are close to each other
using a Hamming distance.
So we define that distance
using a Hamming distance,
and then we search for it
using an approximate hash-based
nearest neighbor search.
And so the result,
if I can switch over
to the other laptop--
let's see if this-- oh yeah.
OK, so this is now the
website running live.
And any of you can go to this
at search.descarteslabs.com.
So first, let's play around
with the United States.
So this is this National
Agriculture Imagery Program
data set that I've
mentioned a few times.
And so I've highlighted
a few popular searches,
but let's click
on wind turbines.
So what this has done is
I've grabbed this tile
and then, like I said,
it is-- we have already
indexed the entire United States
into these 512-bit long feature
vectors.
And it simply searches for
other ones that are similar.
So it's pulled up a whole suite
of different wind turbines
all over the country, so some
here in the midwest, some
in the northeast.
And this is not a
specifically-trained model.
I didn't have to input--
I didn't have to know
anything about wind turbines
to be able to create this.
This is just simply searching
for visual similarity.
Another one I thought was kind
of neat was the solar farms.
So it looks like this is a solar
farm maybe in Arizona or New
Mexico.
So click on that.
And solar farms
look very similar,
so this does quite
well at picking up
solar farm installations.
So let's then also look
at the entire Earth.
So we've done this with the
Landsat data set as well.
And so same idea, being able
to index the entire globe.
So pivot irrigation are
very unique signatures.
I can click on that,
and all of a sudden,
I can see pivot
irrigation in Australia;
over Africa, the sub-Saharan;
in the United States;
down in South America.
So it's a very powerful tool to
be able to effectively search
the entire globe for things.
So you can go to this
today and say, huh,
I want to look for
railway stations that
look similar to the
one near my house.
Let's click on
that and see where
else they are around the world.
And so this is this
incredibly fast search.
And so you can see how quickly
we're able to zoom around.
This is all enabled
by having the platform
built within the Cloud.
So if I can go back
to my talk slides.
Perfect.
So with those two
approaches, there--
we basically have a two-stage
approach to performing searches
when we say we want to try
to find some type of thing.
Because of the capabilities
of the geovisual search,
we can do a low-capacity
quick search
for things like
the wind turbines.
Just click on that.
Or build out a
small model and say,
let's just try to find, roughly,
where some wind turbines are
and differentiate them from corn
fields or forests or whatever.
And then if that's enough
for your particular solution,
super cheap, super
fast and easy.
You're done, no work.
Then, obviously,
many solutions will
require much higher precisions.
Like mapping out
buildings, for example,
wouldn't work with that.
And so then we can develop
a higher capacity model that
takes more time and effort.
And so that's the examples I
showed with buildings or wind
turbines or power substations.
And then, of course,
the last type
of models I want to
talk a little bit about
are hybrid models and
an example of something
we've done that sort of pulls
all these pieces together.
And so what this is, is
one of the original models
that Descartes Labs
produced, which
is the Corn Forecasting Model.
So the goal is to be able
to forecast corn production
for the United States.
So first, as I
mentioned earlier,
using the temporal
information, we
can segment out which--
where different fields are
and what those field types are.
So how this actually
works underneath
is because we have time series
imagery over the United States,
we can just use normal image
processing to find the edges.
It's just an edge detection
within those images.
And then, we can look at
which edges persist over time
and use that as a way to
segment out field boundaries.
Then once we have
those field boundaries,
it becomes a
classification problem.
So taking into
account the spectral
and the spatial
context information,
we can classify those fields.
Here, these are
either corn or soy--
corn in yellow and soy in green.
And what you're
actually seeing here
is the field
classification released
by the US Department
of Agriculture
with a lot of measurements
on the ground.
And what you see here is
what Descartes released
six months ahead of time.
So what you should
say is, hey, look.
Those look pretty much the same.
And they should, because the
US Department of Agriculture
accuracy is quite good.
The key is that we were able
to do this in effectively
real time rather than
having to wait six months.
And then the final
step of that model
is a regression problem, so
saying we have historical data.
We know how much corn
production-- corn
was produced in previous years.
So let's run this model
and fit to a model
to predict how much
corn can be produced.
And so you put all of
those pieces together,
and what the graph on
the right is showing
is the y-axis is the
uncertainty on how well you
have predicted corn.
So small uncertainty is
good, so down is good.
And then as a function of time--
so you can see on
the-- as you go
to the far edge of the graph,
so you extend the time,
they approached
the same accuracy.
But the blue Descartes Labs's
points got there way earlier.
And so this gives
businesses and customers
real actionable
insight that they can
turn into real value in money.
So wrapping that
up, if any of you
are interested in
building models
or if this brings up ideas, feel
free to come up and talk to me.
There's information
on our website.
And then, you can email either
of these email addresses.
And I'd love to talk to you more
about what types of problems
you might be able to approach
with these types of data
or more questions about how
we've been able to build out
all this infrastructure and our
platform using Google Cloud.
So with that, thank
you all for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]